welcome to hurry so bees each Anna where
we discussed the latest tech news and
delve into newest tech products today
we're taking a look at if the GTX 11:8
is actually delayed and if you should
still wait for it but before we delve
into that make sure to hit that
subscribe button if you guys would like
to stay updated with the latest tech
news related to gaming and pcs so what
happened well recently there was an
article from PC games end that suggested
that Nvidia may just skip the 12
nanometers architecture and go straight
for a 7 enemy2 architecture later this
year even though there are so many
rumors saying that the gtx 1180 and 1170
will come out during the summer with the
12 nanometer process throughout the
article the main argument is that all
the rumors surrounding the 1170 and
lemon ad don't originate from a credible
source so it's really just all
speculation and rumors and things of
that nature and as a result they're
suggesting that they get back could all
be false and because of that these
people believe that a medium may do
something completely different in order
to keep their advantage over AMD they're
suggesting that Nvidia may just go for
seven animator crosses at the end of
this year instead of 12 millimeters over
the summer like originally anticipated
because that'll help them better
accentuate their lead over AMD and the
reasoning does make a lot of sense
tsmc who are probably going to be the
silicon manufacturers for Nvidia for
their new graphics cards have already
started volume production of seven
nanometer processors now we already know
that AMD is planning on using TSM C's
new semi nanometer architecture for
their own upcoming line but this may not
be the only reason that TSMC has started
production it may also be because NVIDIA
needs it and here's why
in the past AMD made huge strides in the
CPU segment while Intel just laid back
and watched it all happen and suddenly
when AMD made a lot of progress with
Rison and things of that nature
until started to feel the pressure and
had to rush cars like coffee lake and
add scramble and do a lot of things very
quickly
in the end they're on preparedness led
to a huge market share loss for Intel
Nvidia has definitely taken note of this
and I assume that they are playing to
handle such a situation in a much better
manner AMD is planning on moving to the
seven animator process very soon and I
really doubt that Nvidia is going to
stay on the 12 millimeter architecture
while AMD has already gone to the seven
anumita architecture thus I believe that
in video we'll be more aware of the
long-term benefits of going onto a seven
animator process and so I do believe
that they may just skip the told
animator architecture and go straight
for a seven enemy2 architecture but it
makes more sense for them as a business
so what's happening at AMD are they
bringing up seven nanometers onto the
mainstream graphics cards already well
not quite but it is very possible that
AMD will be showing off their seven
animator graphics silicones to certain
high end applications such as machine
learning by the end of this years well
what about foreign video well
unfortunately there aren't very many
clear science now what they plan to do
with seven nanometers or go millimeters
but what is clear is that I doubt NVIDIA
is going to want to let AMD be on a more
advanced process than what they are so I
really do think NVIDIA is going to go on
to seven innovative process by the time
the AMD gets there we saw something
similar with Intel and AMD for the
enthusiast platform Intel didn't want
AMD to have a highest thread count and
core count CPU on the market at 16 cores
and 32 threads as a result they rushed
out of 18 core 36 thread CPU so in the
past couple of months nvidia may not
have been planning to go to seven amir
process but now judging from the
competition they may have changed their
plans so what does this really mean for
us well it's all really good things when
you think about performance price and
efficiency the only thing that we will
have to do is wait a bit longer
seven nanometers is expected to bring a
60% drop in power consumption and could
possibly lead to a die size
of up to 70% so as you guys can see it
is going to be much more efficient and
hopefully provide much better
performance but what exactly is it going
to come out well we again don't have any
concrete details with Nvidia themselves
or any other credible source but in the
past nvidia has been sticking to at
we're psycho in the past couple of
generations and it has been over two
years since the 10th series came out so
I really do think that we can expect a
new series from Nvidia in the very
imminent future and I really doubt that
they are going to push the 11th series
on to 2019 so I do think that we're
going to see it in the fourth quarter of
this year that way they can still take
advantage of the holiday season of 2018
but that's just why I speculate make
sure to post in the comments down below
what you guys think about that
so should you wait well here's the thing
it really just depends on how badly you
need an upgrade and how much you're
willing to actually wait for it well in
my opinion I really recommend you guys
just wait because it doesn't really make
sense to buy an almost outdated GPU
especially for over MSRP prices so what
about if they got below MSRP
well even if these current GPUs dropped
below MSRP next here is it's coming out
so soon that it still doesn't really
make that much sense also once the new
series comes out the 10th series will
drop even further in price so if you
guys don't want more performance they
nice wait for the eleventh series and
then buy 10 series of graphics card and
they all save money as well however if
you really are just absolutely done
waiting for anything else or you just
really need an upgrade then yes of
course just go ahead and buy a GPU but
if you can at all then just please try
to wait because it really will be worth
the performance overall there has been a
new article that has questioned the
legitimacy of all the rumors surrounding
the gtx 1170 and 1180 and this new
article is suggesting that nvidia mages
go on to a 7 animator process at the end
of the
your instead of 12-minute very process
over the summer in order to be able to
keep their lead over a and B and this is
very possible and despite a possible
delay in the release date I still
recommend that you guys wait for this
next series of GPUs but if we're really
so close to it you guys have been
waiting for so long anyways so you might
as well make the weight worth it so what
do you guys think are you guys glad that
AMD is putting pressure on the GPU scene
as well or are can you just not wait to
get a GPU already make sure comment down
in the comments below what you guys
think because I do read all my comments
and I'm fierce as to what you guys think
so make sure to post your thoughts also
if you guys like this video and make
sure drop a like and hit that subscribe
button if you guys would like to see
more videos just like this but until
next time bye
[Music]